my brother stephen how are you doing i'm
doing well dr john how about yourself
doing good man man how can i help so
my girlfriend and i have been dating for
about a year
um and in the beginning of our
relationship we gained some happy weight
and over the past few months what is
happy weight
just going out to eat and cooking at
home and just experiencing
life during covet and stuff like that
eating probably more than we should
okay um not working out okay and
stephen i'm just gonna tell you right
now i feel like you are setting me up
oh man i have a feeling i know this is
going man
and you're already giving me hives but
go ahead um
and so we've been working out for the
past few months
and with how serious we're getting in
the stuff i have planned in the near
future
the issue of our weight keeps coming up
in our conversations and it's really
kind of pushing back the plans that we
have because it's creating a strain
and i'm trying to figure out if you
could help me out figure out a way to
approach it
in a better way so we can grow our
relationship and get over this hurdle
oh stephen you are being very diplomatic
in your use of pronouns my man
you are saying our and we i need you
just to cut to the chase man
and i'm flinching for what i think
you're about to tell me but go for it
so i've gained about 25 pounds and i
ended up losing
10 pounds from where i started at so i
started at 220 and i'm down about 210
205.
after going up to 240 yes sir okay
and she has gained about 40 pounds
and is continually
doing her best to work out but
unfortunately it's not really helping
out
steven are you calling me to ask
how you can tell your girlfriend
that she's gained weight no we've we've
had conversations
and to the point to where she wasn't
able to afford a gym membership and she
begged me
to get one and i got her the one that
she wanted um
and for the past five months she's gone
nine times
and it's a hundred now it's 135 dollars
a month
and we even changed lifestyles like i
started grilling out took all the junk
food out i stopped drinking alcohol
uh because she said that's one thing she
wanted to do so i was like you know if i
want to make this happen and we want to
make this happen she wants to make this
happen
i have to set an example of what you
know
needs to change and unfortunately
we're having a hard time understanding
each other in this moment
of what we need to do to move forward
and begin to
get to the process of where we want to
be with our physical appearance
oh man stephen there's so much here
and you know that we live in a cancel
culture right if i say the
one wrong thing here i'm done forever
you realize that right
i know and i don't want that to happen
you've just put a ball on a tee for me
and i'm also trying to be nice to you
because i kind of want to set you on
fire right now but that would be rude
and i'd go to jail okay so here's the
thing
i want to just kind of cut through all
of it
okay you've got to let the fantasy go
you are dating somebody who does not
share the same values as you
you are dating somebody who
is speaking the words that you want to
hear
but is making decisions for any number
of reasons
to live how she wants to live which is
different than a value you share
and for some reason you don't want to
see this
that she's not a math problem
and suddenly you're becoming her dad by
fixing her diet
and even the way you just said a month
tells me you got some rage underneath
there brother
yeah i mean it's kind of i have a
personal experience with this because in
higher
late high school or the college i
actually got up to 280 pounds
i know but here's the thing here's the
thing for you
it was a disciplined decision
and a moral decision and a character
issue
and you're assigning your character and
you're assigning your discipline
to somebody else who is not seeing it
that way
and no amount of male
assignment to a young woman is gonna
she's not gonna go oh that's the thing
that's what i ah that's it
thanks man i gained 40 or 50 pounds
because i just didn't know about x
and you changed all of my food and you
bought me a real expensive thing and you
got angry
and you sent me great discipline and
pinterest quotes and you told me about
your journey of weight loss
you lost 70 pounds which is really
impressive by the way
thank you that's what i was missing
thanks man
dude that's not how it's not gonna
happen
so how do i change my my view set on
this
to i guess stephen you leave
hindering steven you're getting all of
the signals you need
okay that's tough it's real
tough because uh
just a few weeks ago i talked to her
parents about some stuff
yeah of course now i might have made an
investment
yeah you're in it brother
oh it's tough it is do you want to leave
her
no she's honest her character's above
approach everything you want
okay stephen okay stephen will you love
her
50 pounds heavier than you have her in a
picture in your mind
yes will you try to be a person who
co-creates a future with her and who
supports her and loves her and doesn't
try to father her
yes
then she's the one for you and i guess i
need to get over that superficial
mindset
hey hold on it's not about that it's not
about that because it's not bad to say
hey
who you were when we dated was 50 pounds
less if i showed up 50 pounds more to my
wife right now
that would be a thing and anyone who
says different than that is not telling
the truth
but at 10 pounds at 20 pounds my wife
would come and sit down and say hey
you're not whole right now are you doing
okay
not hey we should have more fish and
chicken right
yeah and she would know me well enough
to know
that when i said something like i just
need to get some more kettlebells she
would say no man
john you go to the gummy candies when
you're not doing well when you're
stressed when you're anxious
right john you drink more than normal
wind
fill on the blank yeah and if i was
dating somebody
who was crushing it and trying to give
me
dietary tips and trying to
ask me why i wasn't using the expensive
gym membership they bought me
i'd drink more too dude
so i've just been i've been approaching
it completely wrong
um is that is that kind of where you're
getting that
i'm getting it this start treating her
like she is a person to be with and a
person to love
and not a puzzle to solve she is not a
malfunctioning chevy engine that just
needs to get the
uh you know you know new headers
or you know new spark plugs yes sir
yeah so i understand she's dealing with
something in her heart
or she's not or she's not she may think
she's beautiful
and that things are great and she gets
to do that
yeah she does it is beautiful it sounds
like she's told you
she doesn't like the trajectory of where
she's headed that she doesn't like
feeling unhealthy
that she doesn't like um the decisions
she's making which tells me she's got
underlying things
and again don't hear this everybody
listening and say because she put on
weight so you're such a jerk now that's
what i'm saying
i'm saying if somebody is saying
whatever the behavior is i'm out of
control and i can't stop
i've had several of these declarations
in my adult life about my addiction to
sugar
i got a problem dude like a bad problem
and there's been several times that i've
reached out to friends or to my wife and
said i
can't stop i have to not have sugar in
the house
for about a month and i gotta give away
my debit card
and my wife says cool i got you and her
and my kids will go to sonic
without me right they'll sneak and go
while i'm at work right
but that's not about food that's about
something totally different
but i've also had seasons where i'm like
brother it is dissertation time i'm
writing a book time i'm just gonna eat
i'm gonna enjoy my life
i know i'm gonna pay for it later but
i'm gonna have fun with it right and
those are two totally different mindsets
and so if she's not loving the way she
looks and she is heartbroken
i want you to ask her where the
heartbreak comes from i want you to hold
her hands and say i'm not going to give
you any more advice
i'm just going to give you a safe place
to share
or if she says i'm really struggling
with
drinking too much then man that's not a
weight issue brother there's something
else going on
yeah she may be really nervous because
she knows you're about to ask her to
marry her yeah
she may be really nervous because she is
not totally sure about your relationship
or she may just be really nervous
because 2020 sucks
yeah it sure does and she's in the
middle of a pandemic and
and work and whatever and whatever in a
partridge in a pear tree
all that to say is this i can hear in
your heart that you love this girl
and i can hear in your voice that you
are doing the best things that you know
how
and so on behalf of every guy across the
country i want to honor you trying to
love
her the best you can i also want to tell
you
that it's not working yeah and so i'm
going to ask you on behalf of every guy
in america stop
okay okay from this point forward
i want you to ask permission to give
advice
when she tells you something i want you
to say are you asking for my input here
or you just want me to hear you okay
and she may fall over dead she may
absolutely pass out from that new
stephen right yeah for sure um and i
don't want you to beat yourself up
over shallowness and superficiality
right
50 pound weight gain in a year says
something's going on
yes sir okay something's going on right
whether it's physiological it's
biological it's psychological
something's going on there
right and that's not something that fish
and chicken is going gonna solve
okay well i appreciate all the input
you've given me well i appreciate you
being a guy that's
i'll tell you this when you're first
rattling this stuff off i thought you
were setting me up and you're gonna get
me fired
and i was just gonna say mean things to
you after hearing you i actually
i really believe that your heart's in
the right place and you're really trying
to do the best you can
and this is just a hard season for
everybody
i would strongly recommend that you and
your wife go see a premarital counselor
if that's the road you're taking
and you don't have to get engaged to do
that you could say hey i see us spending
some time together in the future
i want to learn ways that i can support
and love you better
and i'm a knucklehead i love my gym time
i love finding new discipline quotes
from jocko
i love finding new keto diet recipes
beefcake2000 right but she doesn't
and you want to learn new ways to
communicate with her and support her and
love her better
to give her a safe place a peaceful
place
and if at the end of the day she chooses
man
i just have no interest in the the
physical health stuff that you're
interested in
i like to eat i like my body i think i'm
beautiful
then you have a choice to make but i
want you to start with listening
start with loving start with leaning
into the relationship part not to the
fish and chicken
fix here's a a a
new program and by the way dude when you
invest money in somebody you love
and it doesn't work out don't hold them
hostage with it
she wanted to go to a really nice gym
she thought that's what it was going to
be
and then you did a cool thing a noble
thing you sprung for expensive gym
and then she probably walked in there
and saw all those super fit people and
all their super
fancy million dollar workout clothes and
she
said nope i'm not going and i know too
many women who've had that exact
experience i know dudes who have
that experience so it is what it is
it's a sunk cost you learned
don't beat yourself up don't beat her up
over it it's expensive yeah
chalk it up man if she's the girl for
you over the next 50 or 60 years you'll
have plenty of those moments and she's
going to buy you something fancy and
she's going to miss the mark on that too
just part of it right